Okay, so it's published live. And here
we have the URL.
Wow, and there you go. The article was
posted indirectly over to our WordPress
site here. Here is how you can use GPT
5.5 to get thousands of new users over
to your website every single day. We're
using GPT 5.5 and I've entered in a SOP,
which tells ChatGPT to go out, search,
and find new and relevant topics, write
on those topics every single day, and
post it over to my website. We've done a
similar video using Cloud Co-work, but
I'll show you how to use it in ChatGPT
for completely free. So, you first want
to enter in developer mode. And to do
so, you need to go over to settings, and
then we're going to head over to apps,
and then we're going to go to I believe
there was a way to add or to toggle on
custom application. Or under advanced
settings, you go to create app. Now,
this is where you have have to actually
connect your different MCPs, right? So,
I went ahead and I connected Word
Rocket. Gave it a name, describe what it
does, and then I entered in the URL,
which is wordrocketapi.com,
and I want to ensure that all
authorization is added on, because
that's how Word Rocket connects over to
your plan. So, once you enable this and
you click create, it will then toggle
you to log in to your Word Rocket
account. And once you've done so, Word
Rocket just ensure that you have a
lifetime agency plan or premium plan.
Once you have the right plan, then as
you can see here, Word Rocket will be
added over to your ChatGPT. So, anything
you can do in Word Rocket, you can now
tell ChatGPT to do it for you. So, we
see we have all the actions here. We can
delete articles, we can generate
articles, we can improve articles, list
articles, so on and so forth. That was
the first connector or application that
we connected. Second application is MCP
360 API. So, the way that we connected
this was again, we went to advanced
settings, we added in the new tool. If
you haven't come across this tool, this
is a secondary tool in which I use. It's
really good because you can use it for
completely free, and there's a endpoint
which allows you to find Google news or
Google trending data. So, the Google
Trends tool, you can also connect that
along with the Google News tool. So,
then you can tell ChatGPT to find what
is trending on Google based upon data.
So, to set this up, just head over to
setup, and then we're going to click our
API key, and we're just going to copy
over our URL, and then we're going to
put our URL directly into the
application setup part of ChatGPT. But
most importantly, click
But most importantly, click no
authorization um when you're setting up
MCP 360 because there's no all
authorization. So, just ensure no
authorization is on there, and then
click create, and MCP 360 will be set
up. If you want to get this full SOP, so
you can follow every step by step, just
comment ChatGPT below and I'll send it
over to you.
But as you can see here, ChatGPT
actually did a really, really good job.
I first gave it the full prompt, and
then I told it that I want you to find
news that are specific for Africa, and
then I want you to find the most popular
article around tech, write the article,
and then post it over to my website. So,
you can see here, called the tool.
First, it called the Word Rocket to
ensure that the brand site map that the
website is all set up on Word Rocket.
And then after it found
the website on Word Rocket, and it found
the brand voice, it then went ahead and
used MCP 360 to search up news that's
new and popular. So, we see here it went
ahead. So, it found the news, and then
it used the generate article to then
generate the article using Word Rocket.
So, it completed the pipeline to Word
Rocket generation, but it could not
publish it because the article is still
generating. So, we can see here, it
found the topic Soup Expands into
Nigeria.
We have the website, we have the site
map, we have the
article elements.
We have the content ID. If I head back
over to Word Rocket here, we can see
that the article has already been
generated on Word Rocket. And it
actually looks really, really good. This
is a really good article here. I like
it. Okay, so let's back head back over
to ChatGPT, and now we're going to tell
it to
So, now we're going to tell it to post
the article on the site live. So, what
happened was because the article takes a
little bit of time, um it couldn't post
a incomplete post. So, ChatGPT just
essentially waited. But I'm actually
pretty impressed. It did a very, very
good job. It was quick, it was easy to
use. All you do is enter in your prompt,
and then you can tell it to find news,
write the article, and then publish. So,
now it's telling me to publish it. Let
me go ahead and click publish. I've
given it access.
Okay, so it's published live. And here
we have the URL.
Let's go ahead and take a look at the
URL. And let's have our fingers crossed
that it posted properly.
Wow, and there you go. The article was
posted indirectly over to our WordPress
site here with our images embedded, with
our internal links.
Very cool.
And as you can see here, our featured
image was set, our SEO meta description
was set, and our post was published
directly over to our WordPress site.
Now, if you want to take this a step
further, if I head over to settings
again,
and I head over to schedules, I can
actually go ahead and manage and create
a schedule. So, I can now tell ChatGPT
to make this a scheduled task every day
at 9:00 a.m. And ChatGPT will actually
go ahead and do that for us. Right? So,
it's went ahead and it's created the
task. So, done every day at 9:00 a.m.,
it's going to run this task. And then I
just can click allow if I want to get
some desktop notifications. So, that's
how easy it is to set this automation up
in ChatGPT. I'll be honest, I feel like
it was actually a little bit easier to
use ChatGPT compared to Cloud. Cloud is
a little bit more advanced, um a little
bit harder to use for the everyday user,
but this was super easy. So, if you guys
want to get my prompts, if you want to
sign up for a lifetime agency deal or
just an agency deal for Word Rocket,
head over to app.wordrocket.ai. I'll see
you in the next one. Take care.